Titans let's make a movie on July 27th
do you like special effects crazy stunts
what about Talent we got none of that
you know their names
Titans Chow but you've never seen them
no right like this oh man what is that
on your shirt right there I'm not even
wearing a shirt go to the movies you
didn't save anything we say broomball
design rated PG coming this summer
the story of Batman's greatest ally it's
me me me and best friend in the whole
world
the movie is time to clean up this city
that actually does look pretty good
they're really making movies about every
superhero has there been a movie about
you there was a Green Lantern movie but
we don't we don't talk about that it's
time they make one about me
I'm afraid it's no I only make movies
about real superheroes why don't they
take us seriously Titans you guys are
never actually doing anything heroic
that wasn't even a crime and you didn't
save anything we save design having a
movie is the only way to be seen as a
real hero what about an arch-nemesis
stop right there Deadpool Deadpool what
why does everybody think I'm Deadpool
I thought Deadpool was a good guy by the
way he should be saying that he's not me
okay cuz I came out like way before he
did no I'm pretty sure you're Deadpool
if we can make you more arch-nemesis
then they will see that we're worthy of
a movie
I'm not interested in fighting a robot
[Music]
what
we're taking you down how are you gonna
do it we need a part of me wanna dance
off
you're gonna annoy me to death with your
waffles
[Music]
weights on the back of my
Buzzbee
[Music]
coming this summer
they're finally going to make a movie
about me Belford the movie they're doing
a movie about the butler before robbing
every other superhero has had their own
movie and it is time for the Teen Titans
to have theirs so they go to Hollywood
to make it happen Jade is a Hollywood
director and she meets the Teen Titans
who are interested in a superhero film
it's time they make one about me and
afraid it's no I only make movies about
real superheroes having a movie is the
only way to be seen as a real hero what
about an arch-nemesis Slade is the
number one enemy of the Teen Titans I'm
the greatest most ultimate super villain
the world has ever seen
ah we say it's late
even saying Slade makes you scared and
in this film he's looking to dominate
the world the world will be under my
control and it's up to the Titans to
stop it for that we're taking you down
Titans go comedy ensues and it's very
silly and very funny and it's just
another big crazy fart packed adventure
was it a fart that was just air leaving
my butt which is a fart normally it's
just us doing a myriad of voices that
was amazing
which call comedy gold ladies and
gentlemen but now we get Will Arnett at
christen Valley Nicolas Cage
it's like prom but thousand times huge
this guy don't know who we is then I
think it's time we tell 13 times go the
serious is like the rainbow 15 times go
to the movies is like a pot of gold at
the end of the rainbow as far as it
coming out July 27th that's ideal
because it's hot movie theaters or air
conditions so I think you should go many
times nine times in fact that's really
all I'm asking
yo what's up everybody's little yatta
here playing the green land and the New
Teen Titans go movie I wanna make sure
everybody go check out our new music
video for the Teen Titans go rap I hope
you enjoyed it don't forget to go see
Teen Titans go to the movies theaters
July 27
[Music]
who are you
this guy don't know who he is oh really
then I think it's time we tell
[Music]
[Music]
animal
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
gossamer terrain boasts that days that
he doing his bags
[Music]
[Music]
in the dark in the [ __ ]
[Music]
teen titans go to the movies July 27
with the quick view they're really
making movies about every superhero has
there been a movie about you there was a
Green Lantern movie but we don't we
don't talk about that it's time they
make one about me
I'm afraid it's no I only make movies
about real superheroes why don't they
take us seriously Titans you guys are
never actually doing anything heroic
that wasn't even a crime and you didn't
save anything we save design
[Applause]
will be under my control world destroyed
[Music]
do you know what makes a real hero it's
not the costumes the gadgets the cool
powers it's having your own movie and
that has always been my dream
what are you doing just giving the
people at the wall our movies not about
Wonder Woman it's about us the Teen
Titans no one wants to see us fool
Wonder Woman inspires people and we do
nuts
yes Wonder Woman is great but I thought
Wonder Woman narrator guy just do your
thing
for the creators of Teen Titans go
it's about courage it's about action
it's the superhero movie to end all
superhero movies
hopefully wasn't a fart that was just
air leaving my but which is a fart Teen
Titans goes to the movies because if
Aquaman can get a movie anyone can
[Music]
[Music]